zusammen und herzlich willkommen zu zdf
heute live ihren live stream zu
aktuellen diskussion und ereignissen
ich glaube mittlerweile können wir alle
ganz dringend mal urlaub von corona
gebrauchen cola ist aber leider weltweit
verbreitet es gibt nur ganz wenige
länder wo quasi nichts los ist deswegen
ist es auch mit dem urlaub dieses jahr
eine schwierige sache aber trotzdem
wegfahren oder zumindest mal so ein paar
tage irgendwo anders hin 50
wahrscheinlich fast jeder auch wenn ich
gerade schon jetzt hier im chat gesehen
habe red lion zum beispiel auf youtube
schreibt besser zu hause bleiben sondern
die pandemie nicht beendet ist trotzdem
viele menschen brauchen trotzdem man
dringenden tapetenwechsel einfach mal
rauskommen was anderes sehen wir
schalten deswegen gleich mal zu unseren
korrespondenten nach istanbul nach paris
und nach kiel um zu gucken was denn wo
vielleicht im europäischen ausland
möglich wäre oder auch in deutschland
und hier für die juristischen fragen ist
der reiserechtler kairo träger mir
gleich zugeschaltet er kann das alles
mit uns auseinander klar sein was darf
man wo wir worauf muss man achten
alle fragen und kommentare zu dem thema
bitte in die dafür vorgesehenen
kommentarspalten ihr kennt das spiel
oder per e mail an der erfreute - live
at zdf.de das wird dann wie auch hier
durchgesteckt wir fangen aber mal an in
der türkei bei meinem kollegen luc wort
hallo istanbul
hallo ich grüße wie ist die lage
entschuldigung wie ist die lage in der
türkei gerade liegt also das ist eine
zweigeteilte lage muss man sagen die
lage in der türkei für die türkischen
bürger ist relativ unbefriedigend bis
dramatisch wir haben ja ein echtes hoch
incidents gebiet ist auch so eingestuft
vom robert-koch-institut das heißt die
zahlen sind in den letzten zweieinhalb
drei wochen durch die decke gegangen
wir haben teilweise hier in istanbul
instanzen von bis zu 900 also sieben
tage incidents zum vergleich in
deutschland 150 und am tag etwa um die
60 bis 70 tausend neuinfektionen in
deutschland zum vergleich
deutschlandweit 24.000 also das ist eine
ganz brenzlige lage und aufgrund dieser
lage hat die regierung hat
staatspräsident er
von angeordnet dass die türkei jetzt wir
haben den fastenmonat ramadan der hat
angefangen bis zum ende dieses
fastenmonats dh bis zum 17
mai in einen kompletten lockdown geht
komplett ist nicht ganz richtig weil es
gibt einige kernbereiche der wirtschaft
die sind ausgenommen bauwirtschaft die
schwerindustrie
aber auch die landwirtschaft die dürfen
weiter arbeiten der rest also
dienstleistungsgewerbe büros die läden
die müssen alle schließen und für die
touristen gilt das alles nicht die
können sich frei bewegen im land aber
klar ist auch es ist kein café offenen
dass man sich setzen kann
es gibt auch kein shoppingcenter in das
man gehen könnte man kann halt am strand
liegen
insofern die hotels auf sind auch die
sind nicht alle geöffnet wegen der
schlechten buchungslage haben natürlich
viele häuser zu das heißt frei bewegen
tatsächlich als türkischer staatsbürger
muss sich da bleiben wo ich bin und wenn
ich von außen komme kann ich lustig
durch die gegend fahren das ist richtig
im zuge dieses lockdown der bis zum 17
mai gilt sind über land reisen also
beispielsweise wenn ich jetzt von
istanbul die aus der großstadt an die
igs wieder nach anteil der an den strand
dann brauche ich dafür eine
sondergenehmigung das hat dazu geführt
dass gestern am letzten tag vor dem
lockdown der also gestern abend begonnen
hat ein riesenandrang hier war auf den
flughäfen an den busbahnhöfen die
autobahn war voll weil der ramadan
insbesondere das sogenannte zuckerfest
zum ende des fastenmonats ist
traditionell eine reisezeit so etwa wie
ostern bei uns da das nutzt man um die
familie zu besuchen oder um sich ein
paar tage ruhe zu gönnen
und um diesen lockdown und den damit
verbundenen reiseverbot zu entgehen sind
eben gestern noch viele türken
aufgebrochen es gibt ja auch einen
gewissen unmut in der bevölkerung dass
das für touristen nicht gilt aber es
sind tatsächlich nur wenige touristen da
zum beispiel russland hat die flüge in
die türkei eingestellt also russische
touristen sind gar nicht mehr da und aus
westeuropa auch relativ wenig es gibt
einige arabische und iranische touristen
aber das hält sich sehr in grenzen
ich muss mal ganz kurz mich an die
zuschauer innen richten es gibt hier ton
beschwerden dass sie uns nicht gut hört
wir versuchen dass gerade im hintergrund
zu fixen hier wird nach dem toningenieur
gerufen den würden wir gerne rufen den
haben wir tatsächlich nicht wir sind ein
kleines team und müssen gucken dass die
eine person in der regie jetzt fünf arme
bekommt und das alles hinzukriegen in
der zwischenzeit macht doch einfach
euren ton ein bisschen lauter und ich
hoffe das regelt sich dann gleich lieber
lügt was ist er mit den ganzen menschen
die hier in deutschland leben und
verwandte in der türkei haben die ja
auch regelmäßig dann dorthin fahren
müssen die irgendwas besonderes beachten
also zunächst einmal gilt wie ich eben
sagte die zahlen sind sehr beunruhigen
das heißt jeder muss sich wenn er
hierher kommt in die türkei zunächst
einmal ganz persönlich die frage stellen
gehe ich dieses risiko ein also die
ansteckungsgefahr ist tatsächlich hoch
und die behörden haben diesen lockdown
ja nicht aus jux und laune verhängt sie
möchten diese hohen infektionszahlen in
den griff kriegen also zunächst einmal
ist das eine gesundheitliche gefahr die
man da ein geht das ist die eine sache
behördlich ist es jetzt so dass sie
beispielsweise wenn sie mit einem
deutschen pass einreisen
es gibt keine einreise beschränkung
außer einem pcr test eher negativ sein
muss das heißt ich muss vor betreten des
flugzeugs dann diesen negativen pcr test
vorliegen ist der da kann ich problemlos
einreisen in die türkei und kann mich
innerhalb der türkei dann als tourist
auch bewegen also da gibt es keine
beschränkung das problem ist wenn ich
zurückkomme
aus diesem hoch incidents gebiet wie
gesagt das ist so die türkei ist vom
robert-koch-institut als hoch incidents
gebiet eingestuft werden
da muss sich neben der digitalen
anmeldungen die reise anmeldung muss ich
eben auch wieder einen negativen pcr
test vorliegen der am tag der abreise
oder davor gemacht wurde und ich muss
dann wenn ich zurück bin in deutschland
zehn tage in die amtliche quarantäne
das heißt nur mal eben aus dem exil ohne
eine woche urlaub in der türkei ist dann
verbunden mit zehn tage quarantäne in
deutschland muss man sich also gut
überlegen ob sich das rechnet
kann man sich denn bei seinen ganz
normal bei seinen verwandten dann
einquartieren die man das vielleicht
häufig macht oder gibt es da dann auch
wieder so strenge beschränkungen dass
man eigentlich nur ins land kommt wenn
man sagen kann hier ich habe eine
hotelbuchung also die hotelbuchung wird
meines wissens nicht amtlich von
türkischer seite überprüft aber es wird
natürlich empfohlen weil im prinzip gilt
die auflage hier in der türkei
das familien sich nicht besuchen dürfen
also es gilt jetzt für menschen die hier
in der türkei leben aber eben auch für
zugereiste verwandte dann aus dem
ausland also wird das im einzelfall
überprüft bei 80 millionen einwohner
natürlich schwer zu sagen aber trotzdem
die auflage gilt es gibt keine privat
besucher insofern es ist sicherlich
sinnvoll wenn man so etwas vorhat seine
türkischen verwandten zu besuchen dann
auch das mit einer hotelbuchung zu
kombinieren und dann eigentlich sich
nichts zu hause zu treffen weil das wäre
dann ja in der türkei illegal
eine frage die habe ich hier können wir
kurz zeigen auf meinem rechner von willi
türkei habe ich eventuell einen vorteil
wenn ich mich impfen lasse also keine
quarantäne zum beispiel in der türkei
amtlich ist da noch nichts geregelt die
türkische regierung hat noch keine
maßnahmen ergriffen wie es
möglicherweise zu einer bevorzugung für
geimpfte kommt das sind im moment etwa
22 millionen dosen verimpft in der
türkei 13 millionen haben die erste 9
millionen türken schon die zweite
impfung also das geht relativ zügig
voran
aber dass die geimpften jetzt
sonderrechte wie das ja gerade in der
bundesrepublik diskutiert wird haben das
so weit ist man hier noch nicht es gibt
jedenfalls da keine amtlichen
bevorzugung für geimpfte glück vielen
dank für die infos aus der türkei du
musst weitermachen du hast noch ein
bisschen was zu tun eben um über die
aktuelle lage zu berichten danke dass du
dir die zeit genommen hast gerne zu ihr
kamen gerade schon die frage gibt es
noch was anderes außer der türkei wir
schalten gleich zu crystal haas nach
paris die wird uns sagen wie es in
frankreich und in spanien aussieht und
wir schalten außerdem nach kiel zu
meinem kollegen hermann bernd der wird
uns sagen was man an der ostsee und in
norddeutschland zu machen kann jetzt
spreche ich aber erstmal mit kairo
träger in würzburg der ist rechtsanwalt
mit schwerpunkt reiserechts hallo herr
roth reger dadurch grüße sie was ist
denn gerade die empfehlung der
bundesregierung was urlaub angeht da hat
sich nichts geändert vor nicht
notwendigen reisen wird nach wie vor
abgeraten ganz egal ob es in land- oder
auslandsreisen ist also man will den
bürgern
eigentlich zu hause behalten aber wer
reisen will der darf natürlich reisen es
gibt also kein rein zu fahren
was ist denn wenn ich jetzt in der
türkei sind wir haben gerade über den
tod gesprochen und nicht da nicht an
corinna regeln halte eventuell dann von
der polizei festgehalten werde muss ich
mir da tatsächlich sorgen machen dass es
da zu schlimmeren konsequenzen kommen
könnte haben sie schon mal solche fälle
gehört ja allerdings es geht natürlich
dann das recht der türkei also da hat
man als tourist keine keinen
ausnahmestatus sondern wenn man sich vor
ort nicht an die regeln hält womöglich
gegen quarantäne regeln verstößt dann
kann das sehr teuer werden es drohen
auch durchaus haftstrafen
umgekehrt ist das bei uns in deutschland
nicht anders wenn touristen nach
deutschland kommen und sich nicht an die
quarantäne verordnungen halten auch dann
drohen hohe bußgelder nach dem
infektionsschutzgesetz also davon kann
man nur abraten hier irgendwie sich um
bestimmungen der reiseländer rum zum
mauscheln und irgendwie versuchen ohne
komplikationen sein urlaub zu verleben
und die krone regel nicht zu missachten
das sollte man tunlichst vermeiden wenn
ich jetzt schon gebucht habe und
verstelle ich komme aus irgendeinem
grund nicht mehr ins land was passiert
dann wenn man jetzt eine pauschalreise
gebucht hat und nach der buchung ändert
sich die situation im land die einreise
sind bestimmungen werden sehr viel
stärker zum beispiel es wird eine
quarantäne pflicht auferlegt dann kann
man als pauschaltourist eine notbremse
ziehen das wort notbremse gerade in
vieler munde
das ist dann der kostenfreie rücktritt
weil ein unvermeidbarer
außergewöhnlicher umstand eingetreten
ist nach reisebuchung muss das passieren
wohlgemerkt der individualreisen ist der
schlechter gestellt wer also nur einen
flug in die türkei gebucht und der flug
wird angeboten von der airline und
touristen können auch mit sie dir auf
dem rhein reisen müssten dann aber nur
in quarantäne
da kann ich nicht kostenfrei vom flug
zurücktreten also in diesen tagen oder
in diesem ganzen jahr kommt man
eigentlich dazu raten eine pauschalreise
er zu buchen als individual weil man
besser abgesichert ist
aber auch die frage wenn ich jetzt denke
sogar das ist langsam brenzlich da die
situation scheint da doch über zu kochen
wie in der türkei zum beispiel es gibt
noch keine reisewarnung oder es gibt
noch keine wirklich keine reisestopp
aber mir weder wird das zu unangenehm
muss ich dann quasi auf eigene kosten
sagen sorry ich bin raus oder kann ich
mich da irgendwie absichern oder gibt es
da eine kulanz der reiseveranstalter
hobbys kulanz der reiseveranstalter gibt
muss man bei seiner jeweiligen
reiseveranstalter hinterfragen denn die
bieten natürlich entsprechende
rücktritts möglichkeiten an wenn man nur
aus sorge nicht reisen bild die
reisebranche hat also darauf reagiert
aber von rechtlichen her ist es so wer
nur aus reiner sorge seinen urlaub ab
sagt weil er jetzt wieder was neues
gelesen hat über krone und deswegen
einfach ungutes gefühl hat zu reisen der
bleibt auch stornokosten sitzen also nur
wenn es zu massiven beeinträchtigungen
am urlaubsort kommt dann kann man eben
kostenfrei zurücktreten aber eben nicht
nur aufgrund einer allgemein sorge so
jetzt haben wir hier viele fragen von
euch zu spezifischen ländern wir haben
zwar viele korrespondenten in ganz
europa auf der ganzen welt aber die
haben nicht alle gleichzeitig zeit
gehabt die wir andere sachen zu tun wie
gesagt drei konnten wir für uns gewinnen
und herren rodegra das ist sehr schön
aber jetzt fragen nach griechenland
italien usa polen können sie da
irgendwas sagen weil ich weiß dass
unsere korrespondentin und dafür jetzt
nicht gerade zuständig sind ja da kann
man sich tagesaktuell informieren beim
auswärtigen amt da kann man über jedes
reiseziel dieser erde die aktuellen
einreisebestimmungen ja herausfinden
also muss man einen pcr-test ein
negativen vorweisen geht womöglich eine
quarantäne pflicht als alle pflichten
die man haben muss wenn man einreisen
bild kann man für jedes land nachlesen
und in diesen tagen lohnt es sich auch
der tagesaktuell mal nachzuschauen es
kann nämlich jeden tag eine änderung
eintreten wo sie gerade griechenland
ansprechen da ist ganz aktuelle
änderungen eingetreten da dürfen nämlich
jetzt zweifach geimpfte personen ohne
pcr test schon einreisen und
öffnen auch immer mehr länder ihre
pforten für bereits geimpfte personen
also diese diskussion welche
erleichterungen kämpfte bekommen werden
in diesem sommer die nimmt immer mehr
fahrt auf und immer mehr länder
signalisieren geimpfte personen werden
bei uns leichter haben einst verweist er
aber dekra vielen dank erstmal wir
sprechen gleich weiter quasi wenn wir
mit den beiden kolleginnen durch sind
die jetzt auch berichten werden wie es
bei ihnen aussieht fragen weil ich hier
die besonders nett merkt euch
juristische fragen also herr roth rica
ist jetzt niemand der sagen kann ja in
griechenland sieht so aus sondern es
geht um juristische fragen zu klären wer
gleich weiter wir schalten jetzt aber
einfach mal nach paris zu crystal hat
die steht wie sich das gehört mit einem
schönen blick vom eiffelturm dass sie
dabei kalt auf 7 christel wenn ich
ehrlich sein soll
wann hast du gerade einen fanclub tor
hinter dem oder was passiert da wir
versuchen also ansonsten bereich sie
einfach weiter mal gucken was sie sagen
wenn sie im deutschen fernsehen
christel erst mal vielleicht zu
frankreich du bist ja zuständig für
frankreich und für spanien
rechts schwerpunkt wie sieht die lage in
frankreich gerade aus in frankreich ist
im vergleich zu deutschland die inzidenz
noch sehr hoch im augenblick in
frankreich von deutscher sicht auch auf
als hoch incidents gebiet das heißt man
soll eigentlich nicht hierher reisen
man kann das natürlich aber eigentlich
sind touristen hier dürfen nicht rein
reisen weil man braucht einen triftigen
grund um nach frankreich einzureisen
das können zum beispiel verwandte seien
das kann sein wenn man an kranken
angehören oder wenn man beruflich zu tun
hat und man braucht einen negativen pcr
test der nicht älter ist als 72 stunden
dazu kommt dass hier im augenblick
natürlich noch ein locker und hersteller
wir haben eine ausgangssperre die um 19
uhr beginnt und bis 6 uhr morgens dauert
bis auf die supermärkte und einige
besondere geschäfte die für den wirklich
lebensnotwendigen bedarf da sind sind
alle anderen geschäfte zu auch die
restaurants und cafés es gibt aber jetzt
zumindest eine kleine einen kleinen
lichtblick denn am 19
mai sollen zumindest die terrassen
wieder aufmachen und das freut natürlich
jeden franzosen und vor allen dingen
jeden pariser denn die terrassen gehören
natürlich zu paris dazu das ist schon
sehr traurig wenn man sieht dass alles
zu hat das heißt der romantischen
liebesurlaub in paris könnte ziemlich
trist ausfallen gibt es dann irgendwo
gebiete in frankreich wo du jetzt sagen
würde es okay da kann man hin weil es
nicht so eine hohe instituts zahl gibt
oder weil es dort vielleicht auch ein
bisschen besser essen oder zu machen
zunächst mal ab dem 9 juni sollen
touristen wieder ins land kommen wenn
denn alles so läuft wie man sich das
erhofft und die inzidenz zahl runter
geht dann sollen eben auch die geschäfte
theater die kinos natürlich mit einem
bestimmten mit einer bestimmten besucher
begrenzung wieder auf haben und auch die
restaurants im innenbereich paris würde
ich jetzt im augenblick noch nicht
empfehlen weil da ist tatsächlich sind
die zahlen sehr sehr hoch auch marseille
ist noch so ein hoch gebiet aber was
ganz gut ist ist die bretagne und die
gesamte atlantikküste und auch die
region um nizza herum
da ist die intelligenz sehr stark
gefallen
man hat aber da auch sehr früh einen
lock down verhängt und das macht sich
offenbar jetzt bemerkbar also das sind
so die gebiete die nicht so belastet
sind und wo man wenn man als tourist
nach frankreich reisen will
den fand könnte was ist mit
campingplätzen das ist ja auch ein
beliebtes ziel so in der bretagne zum
beispiel also die campingplätze bereiten
sich jetzt vor auf den großen ansturm
erst mal der franzosen weil ab montag
nämlich der 10 km radius der für uns
hier gilt im ganzen land jeder darf
nicht weiter als zehn kilometer von
seinem wohnort sich entfernen
und der soll wegfallen und man kann
wieder im ganzen land umherreisen und
viele franzosen stürmen jetzt quasi oder
buchen jetzt die campingplätze weil die
franzosen natürlich auch ganz
begeisterte camper sind man kann also da
bestimmt auch als deutscher tourist wenn
man dann ab dem 19 juni einreisen kann
und das alles auch ein bisschen besser
ist durchaus auch auf einem campingplatz
übernachten
es wird da auch beschränkungen geben
wahrscheinlich werden nicht alle plätze
vermietet werden man muss natürlich auch
dort abstand halten man muss die maske
tragen
das sind auflagen die einfach für alle
gelten und noch weiterhin gelten werden
ich habe schön kommentare gerade von
martina ihren auf facebook beschreibt
wenn ich nach frankreich möchte laufe
ich hier durch den wald oder bei
verwandten durch den garten an sony
scheint in der deutsch französischen
grenze zum wohnen das ist schön für sie
das glück hat nicht jeder
christel du bist auch für spanien
zuständig wie sieht es dann in spanien
aus das war ja noch lange zeit wirklich
richtig schwierig dort
das war lange zeit sehr sehr schwierig
jetzt ist es deutlich besser die
inzidenz liegt glaube ich bei 117 oder
so irgendetwas also gar nicht mehr so
hoch allerdings gilt spanien gibt die
gibt es noch eine reisewarnung des
auswärtigen amtes für spanien
allerdings sind einige gebiete
ausgenommen zum beispiel galizien zum
beispiel muss ich ja zb valencia und die
balearen man kann also auf die balearen
reisen ohne probleme und dort urlaub
machen
das einzige was man braucht ist einen
negativen pcr test wir haben es ja auch
gesehen schon über ostern das war ja so
eine testphase dass man dahin reisen
durfte es sind die terrassen offen aber
noch nicht die restaurants im inneren
man muss also draußen sein und das gilt
auch dort eine ausgangssperre allerdings
ist das immer von region oder stadt zu
stadt unterschiedlich die hoteliers
bereiten sie für insgesamt natürlich
auch den sommer vor aber sie wollen
jetzt gar keine feste planung weil sie
aus erfahrung wissen das kann sich alles
ganz ganz schnell ändern
insofern gucken sie auf die
infektionszahlen und richten sich dann
danach wie es weitergehen soll aber
natürlich hofft spanien dass touristen
kommen denn der tourismus ist ja eine
ganz ganz große große hat einen großen
stellenwert in in spanien das ist ein
großer wirtschaftsfaktor und die
regierung hat jetzt auch schon die
europäischen touristen eingeladen doch
nicht für den sommerurlaub schon
buchungen vorzunehmen also man rechnet
damit dass dann alles besser wird aber
wie gesagt man muss immer schauen
dieses virus ist ein bisschen schwierig
haben wir ja gelernt was geht denn
entspannen überhaupt und wie ich habe
auch heute mal geguckt madrid ist glaube
ich so richtig noch hoch instituts
gebiet mit einer inzidenz von über 200
tickets auf einen kommentar von jens man
da schreibt madrid plant schon wieder
fürs super spreading das klingt jetzt
für mich so als ob generell so eine
städtetour nicht nur die beste idee
sie ist vielleicht auch nicht zu
empfehlen madrid fährt so eine sonder
strategie durch die die regional
präsentiert sind dort die setzt auf
öffnung das heißt es sind die geschäfte
und die restaurants auf und es gibt aber
auch eine abendliche ausgangssperre ich
glaube ab 22 uhr wo man dann nicht mehr
draußen sein kann und dann möglichst zu
hause sein soll
die museen und auch im begrenzten umfang
theater sind auch offen das ist soll
einfach zeigen dass man weiter lebt dass
man mit dem virus lebt aber die inzidenz
zahlen wie gesagt immer tritt sind jetzt
und auch in barcelona sind deutlich
höher als in anderen regionen spaniens
hier ist ein kommentar von kim figl
gerade hier auf youtube beschreibt in
madrid hat fast alles offen
das ist ja doch schon sehr ungewöhnlich
dass die spanische regierung da so eine
strategie fährt also da wird quasi
einfach gehofft dass es gut ausgeht
na ja das ist ja so ähnlich wie bei uns
in deutschland wobei geht spanien kann
föderaler staat ist aber die haben
natürlich auch regionen die eine
bestimmte selbstbestimmung haben und wie
man mit dem virus umgeht und mit der
pandemie und was man öffnet und was man
nicht öffnet es sei denn es gibt einen
nationalen lockdown das entscheiden eben
die regionen und madrid hat entschieden
wir machen so viel aufgeht und wir
hoffen auf das impfen und wir hoffen
darauf dass die leute sich an die
maßnahmen halten an den abstand an die
masken und so weiter und bislang ist es
aber auch so dass es scheinbar gar nicht
so schlecht gelaufen ist denn es hat
sich jetzt nicht dramatisch
verschlechtert es ist jetzt auch nicht
dramatisch besser geworden aber insofern
kann man jetzt nicht sagen das ist
schlecht gelaufen und viele genießen das
natürlich auch und ich glaube das reizt
natürlich auch viele touristen aus
deutschland oder auch aus frankreich
nach madrid zu fahren aber man sollte es
sich wirklich gut überlegen klima kann
auch mal ein kommentar
hinterhergeschoben ausgangssperre ist
hier ab 23 uhr in madrid keiner beachtet
sie na ja was ist dann die hoffnung von
der gerade sprach die spanier sind ein
bisschen
wir waren jetzt leider nicht mehr in
spanien eben aufgrund der pandemie
insofern gar nicht dann habe ich es mit
eigenen augen nicht gesehen habe ich
kann mir das natürlich vorstellen
das ist hier bei uns in frankreich auch
es gibt natürlich partys nachts
es gibt leute die sich auf der straße
treffen oder bei freunden zuhause für
frankreich würde ich sagen ist das
dennoch eine eine minderheit obwohl es
immer wieder berichtet wird aber ich
finde die franzosen haben sich extrem
gut an diesem lockdown und in die
maßnahmen gehalten
in spanien ist es vielleicht noch ein
bisschen eine andere persönlichkeit es
kann sein dass es da ein bisschen mehr
ist aber das kann ich leider nicht
beurteilen ich habe es nicht aus eigenen
augen gesehen gut dann verlassen wir uns
auf den augenzeugenbericht von christel
vielen dank für diese information über
frankreich und spanien
und wie es im rest von europa ausgehen
haben wir uns auch angeguckt die lage
ist sehr unterschiedlich
das haben michael weber trio land in
avignon und für uns zusammengefasst
endlich wieder ans meer fahren endlich
wieder gemeinsam in den urlaub und dort
ins restaurant während in deutschland
hotels und gaststätten weiter
geschlossen sind öffnen andere länder
wieder
aber was es zu beachten vorab sollte man
sich informieren ob das wunschland
derzeit ein hoch incidents oder ein
risikogebiet ist denn unabhängig von den
regeln vor ort gelten vorschriften bei
der wiedereinreise nach deutschland
alle die per flugzeug in die
bundesrepublik einreisen müssen noch vor
dem abflug der fluggesellschaft ein
negatives testergebnis vorlegen
dies ist unabhängig davon ob ein land
ein risikogebiet ist oder nicht ist das
land ein risikogebiet so muss eine
einreise anmeldungen vorliegen es muss
spätestens 48 stunden nach einreise ein
negatives testergebnis eingereicht
werden und es besteht eine zehntägige
quarantäne pflicht in fünf tagen mit
einem zweiten test verkürzt werden kann
bei der einreise aus einem hoch
incidents gebiet ist zu beachten dass
reisende sich bereits vor abflug testen
lassen müssen
so es gibt aber auch viele leute die in
deutschland bleiben wollen und die lage
im land ist hat durchaus sehr
unterschiedlich ein lieblings
urlaubsgebiet von vielen deutschen ist
die nord und ostsee und dafür ist
herrmann bernd zuständig in kiel
zugeschaltet neuen herren ja auch neun
zurück die lage in schleswig holstein
ist ja noch relativ entspannt oder ja
das ist genauso genauso kann man es
beschreiben also ich habe heute wieder
den satz gehört wir sind ja die insel
der seligen die der inzidenz wird
pendelt so um die 70 landesweit in kiel
in den übrigen flensburg ist manchmal
ein bisschen höher gewesen
in flensburg liegt er jetzt zum beispiel
auch wieder zurückgegangen bei 30 aber
landesweit um die 70 und wenn man also
auf die karte guckt haben wir hier im
norden immer eine andere farbe und es
gibt halt immer wieder auch eine
humorvolle ursachenforschung sage ich
mal
woran liegt das liegt daran dass es das
land zwischen den meeren ist liegt es
vielleicht auch an der mentalität der
norddeutschen und verrat ist ich wollte
sagen ja
letzteres kann ich nur bestätigen also
zum beispiel diese berühmte
abstandsregel ein meter fünfzig das für
den norddeutschen viel zu nahe
also vier meter ist schon viel besser
also so geht man damit um und man hält
sich hier halt auch sehr an die regeln
und vielleicht sind diese drei punkte
also lager einhalten der regeln und
natürlich auch die mentalität ein grund
dafür ja ihr volk grad sagen ja wenn
auch nicht viel geredet was man einmal
losgeht und 99 ist momentan schweiz
seine ja ich habe hier ein kommentar
gleich von 11 auf urlaub in kiel sollte
doch möglich sein ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob das nicht vielleicht
surfurlaub heißen sollte geht eins davon
also auf urlaub geht gar nicht also
natürlich gibt es hier wie überall in
deutschland auch kontrollen ob regeln
eingehalten werden und die geld
natürlich auch in kiel
hier gibt's natürlich ausnahmen die
ist ja bestimmt bekannt geworden auch
südlich der elbe dass die
außengastronomie inzwischen geöffnet ist
und das funktioniert auch sehr gut man
muss sich dann trotzdem anmelden ob beim
einkaufen natürlich registrieren
also es ist nicht einfach so dass man
hierher kommt und zu fünft oder zu zehnt
irgendwie an der kiellinie sitzt und
hemmungslos bier bringt das läuft nicht
wo kann ich denn überhaupt an der kiste
urlaub machen das ganze auch diese diese
modellversuche bei euch irgendwo an der
küste
genau das ist wirklich ein auch
wissenschaftlich begleitetes sage ich
mal urlaubs experiment touristisches
experiment seit dem 22
april sollte es laufen in vier regionen
und zwar einmal in dithmarschen in büsum
dann nordfriesland sylt amrum und föhr
mit den nordfriesischen inseln
eckernförde und für die hamburger auch
ganz interessant über die lübecker bucht
mit timmendorfer strand travemünde
scharbeutz aber angefangen hat
eigentlich vor am 22
also vor knapp 14 tagen eckernförde und
die schlei region also ostsee und ich
habe eben noch mal nachgeguckt ganz
interessante zahlen also zu diesem
konzept gehört halt gehören zwei
wesentliche dinge einmal di luca app die
man vorzeigen muss wenn man irgendwo
bucht natürlich und ein negativer corona
tests das sind die wesentlichen dingen
wesentlichen punkte und der korona
testen ist auch je nachdem wo man es
alle zwei oder drei tage wiederholt
werden
also das sind schon sehr strenge regeln
und für den ein oder anderen auch
einschränkung ich habe auch gehört auf
schild zum beispiel war die buchungslage
extrem gut aber einige haben wegen
dieser regeln dann doch wieder
zurückgezogen also ganz spannend aber
was heißt das jetzt konkret ich meiner
sind ja auch gebiete da fad hast du
gerade gesagt herr fahren fahren die
hamburger gerne mal hin oder auch die
hannoveraner das ist ein tagesausflug
weit weg läuft man nicht gefahr jetzt
auch langes wochenende oder jetzt
maiwochenende das einen drauf einmal die
brühe überläuft und wir dann dicht
gedrängte der strände haben ja das muss
man differenziert sehen also die die
buchung in den in den hotels in den
ferienwohnungen die müsse er vor
vorgenommen werden
genau wer kommt das problem in
norddeutschland ist wie du es richtig
beschrieben was auch immer das wetter
und die tagesausflügler aber das kann
man nicht so genau steuern jetzt ist für
für morgen und also morgen beginnt es in
nordfriesland und auch schuld und morgen
beginnt es auch in büsum jetzt ist das
wetter eher durchwachsen also geht man
davon aus dass jene kommen die oft
vorher gebucht haben auch ihren
campingplatz gebucht haben ihre
ferienwohnung ihr hotel und das ist dann
nicht so voll läuft problematisch ist
immer wenn möglich das wetter traumhaft
ist andere gerne an die bilder vom
vergangenen sommer von der von der
lübecker bucht also als die parkplätze
so rappelvoll waren und am strand auf
koh so der ampel eingeführt wurde also
dass es kann passieren würde aber
diesmal nicht weil das wetter nicht so
toll werden soll hier ist eine schöne
kommentar von canal canal ritter ohne
kann man wenigstens feuerquallen fangen
an der aussie du hast ein merkwürdiges
hobby würde ich sagen ein bisschen
ungesund ganz witzig ich war eben noch
mal unser büro liegt ja man sieht es ja
nicht weit weg von der kieler förde und
ich kann den den herren oder wer immer
es war nicht beruhigen
es ist noch kein quallen alarm ok also
da das könnte noch kommen aber ist ja
vielleicht noch ein bisschen kalt dafür
was ist denn mit camping eigentlich
campingplatz einer anderen orten
aussehen das ist ja auch wäre doch eine
gute alternative viele sagen das ist
doch sicher dass man draußen da kann man
nichts passieren alle argumente genannt
und deswegen ist es auch super in also
ich war heute auf den campingplatz karls
finde so heißt der bulli überlack gucken
bei eckernförde hat 600 plätze
stellplätze und da sieht man die bilder
und da sieht man auch da ist platz am
strand da ist auch abstand zwischen den
wohnwagen also das ja aber das bleibt
auch so
da passen die auf der 600 leute hin und
der campingplatzbetreiber sagte mir
heute als vor 14 tagen das experiment
modellregion geöffnet wurde hatten sie
innerhalb von drei tagen 7000 anfragen
aber jetzt muss ja noch differenzieren
von den 600 plätzen sind 500 dauercamper
und die
die dann da sieht es sind diese plätze
für urlaube das sind so 80 bis 100 und
werde das ist wie ein sechser im lotto
sagt mir die urlauber heute also und
genießen das natürlich das war ein
traumtag direkt am wasser und ist ja
jetzt auch keine neuigkeit dass der
trend zu wohnmobilen geht 100.000
verkaufte warum mobile letztes jahr und
die campingplatzbetreiber ja die denken
weiter also ausweitung der plätze noch
mehr plätze
also es ist ein großes thema hier im
norden ganz wichtig jetzt zu sagen es
gibt noch andere campingplätzen nicht
dass er jetzt wieder schleichen wir
kriegen eva dort auch schon geschrieben
auf youtube wir machen camping in
deutschland war es schon seit jahren
machen dafür geimpft sind wir jetzt
bestimmt klappen mit den ferien im juli
was ist denn aber sonst so generell
würdest du sagen ferienwohnung ist das
ein thema da weiß ich auch dass ja auch
ganz ganz große schwierigkeiten das ist
ein ss dürfte gar nicht mehr machen oder
zweitwohnung auf sylt solche menschen
soll es ja auch geben da dürft ihr nicht
hin ist das mittlerweile geregelt
ja das hat sich ein bisschen entspannt
das war schon mit der zweitwohnungen
zahlt dann relativ schwierig weil ja es
ist ja im grunde auch ein privileg und
viele die aus großen städten köln
stuttgart frankfurt kommen haben die
gelegenheit genutzt und und auch diese
harten monate sage ich mal auf sylt dann
ihre geschäfte online gemacht so home
office aus sulz sowas gab es und es kam
nicht so gut an aber die diskussion hat
sich inzwischen gelegt weil natürlich
jetzt auch der blick ganz anders ich
weitet jetzt kommen morgen erstmal geht
es richtig los mit der modellregion da
lebt man ja auch vom tourismus
man ist so hin und hergerissen man freut
sich auf der einen seite öko es geht
wieder los wenn ein geschäft auf der
anderen seite sagt mir heute eine
geschäftsfrau aus äckern schade ja so
wir sind halt von natur aus ein bisschen
skeptisch ist mir schon zu voll ich gehe
lieber nicht an stand also es ist immer
so eine so eine zwiespältige stimmung
gut dann gucken wir mal wie es läuft mit
diesen modellregionen wir sind gespannt
auf eure berichte aus kiel und ich sage
vielen dank
für deine eindrücke die vielen dank auch
und dann schauen wir noch mal zu unserem
rechtsanwalt nach würzburg wo ich glaube
noch ein paar fragen offen sind zur
juristischer art zu kairo dekra ich
hoffe die leitung steht das signal aus 9
das habe ich jetzt habe ich das
norddeutsche drinnen sorry ich bin auch
hamburg
okay an geht alles gut genau wir haben
gerade die frage schon mal versucht zu
beantworten was es mit ferienwohnungen
oder mit zweitwohnungen ist das jetzt in
deutschland generell kein problem mehr
doch es ist ein problem wenn die
inzidenz über 100 steigt da haben wir
gehört dass letzte woche diese notbremse
in kraft getreten ist und wenn sie über
100 ist dann dürfen touristische
übernachtungen nicht mehr angeboten
werden also sagen muss man sich immer
genau erkundigen
eventuell gibt es auch deinen ausnahmen
region also da muss man dann im
zielgebiet sich erkundigen was ist bei
euch möglich und was nicht und
insbesondere bei der inseln auch immer
tagesaktuell nachfragen so wir haben
natürlich auch viele kommentatoren die
sagen das ganze ist mir zu zu
autoritäres ich werd drangsaliert möchte
ich einfach frei bewegen auch halte mich
an die an die regeln oder auch mit den
impfungen doktor stone schreibt hier auf
youtube ich denke sollte erlaubt sein
nach berechnungen der cdu und der stiko
haben wir gegen juli genug impfstoff für
alle erwachsenen in deutschland und
verkauft wird auch entsprechend schnell
wenn wir das impf tempo von einem
prozent pro tag aufrecht halten ist
jeder impfwillige in zwei monaten
geimpft könnte das bedeuten dass wir im
august im grunde dann durch sind und
lustig wieder normalen urlaub fahren
können
also ich hoffe es natürlich so sehr wie
alle anderen auch wieder zuschauer jetzt
auch aber ob er damit durch sind kann
auch ich nicht sagen aber was man jetzt
schon mit bekommt geimpfte werden auf
jeden fall erleichterungen bekommen und
das geht ja auch schon in deutschland
los wir hatten das eben schon in der
sendung das erwähnt wurde wenn man aus
einem risikogebiet zurück nach
deutschland kommt dass ein eine
quarantäne erwartet das wurde jetzt
schon in einigen bundesländern
aufgehoben zum beispiel rheinland-pfalz
baden-württemberg bayern
auch hessen dort ist es so wenn man eine
zweifach-impfung schon gehabt hat und
das nachweisen kann dann entfällt diese
quarantäne pflicht und wie ich auch in
der erste schalte schon gesagt habe
immer mehr länder verzichten auch bei
der einreise auf einen negativen corona
test wenn man nachweisen kann dass man
geimpft ist also zumindestens die
geimpften können sich ja auf einem
beschwerdefreien sommer würde ich mal
sagen freuen und die anderen dürfen wir
auch verreisen nur müssen die sicherheit
dieser prozedur einer einer testung
stets unterziehen soll ich muss mal kurz
in die kommentare gehen weil wir haben
ja auch die üblichen vorwürfe wir würden
ihre propaganda machen oder ddr tv die
wir so ein jahr machen wir hier nicht
wir versuchen noch niemandem ein zu
reden was er tun oder lassen soll wir
sprechen nur ganz deutlich aus was die
fakten sind nämlich es gibt länder in
europa da ist die instanz höher und da
ist das risiko entsprechend auch über
das du dir eine infektion einfängt ob du
das möchte es ist dir selbst überlassen
es gibt natürlich auch teilweise
schwierigkeiten dort urlaub zu machen
wie das halt so ist das hat ganz ganz
sicher mit mit euren vorwürfen finde ich
wirklich befremdlich teilweise also
wirklich merkwürdig aber gut nehmen wir
zur kenntnis ich habe eine sehr schöne
frage hier von sven odenthal
was ist denn wenn ich aus dem flieger
steige und sich an dem tag neue
bestimmungen ergeben also von trapp
flugs zeitpunkt bis zur ankunft am
flughafen sagen mal wirklich die steige
wenn sie in münchen einen flughafen
einsteigen und während man nach antalya
fliegt ändert sich alles und die türken
sagen sorry kommt es nicht mehr rein
ja das ist dann pächtern gilt das recht
des landes daran muss ich mich halten
aber dass ein gänzlich zu machen also
niemand mehr rein lässt das ist er nicht
vorstellbar dass das von innerhalb von
stunden passiert aber es kann natürlich
eine verschärfte tests pflicht
eingeführt werden und dem muss man sich
dann unterwerfen wenn man ankommt an
ziel und möglicherweise muss man auch in
quarantäne gehen obwohl diese bestimmung
vorher noch nicht war aber im normalfall
sind solche bestimmung corinna bedingt
der schutzmaßnahmen und bestimmungen
kommen nicht von einer stunde auch die
anderen im normalfall so dass man sich
darauf vorbereiten kann
im tagesverlauf hat ist man allemal das
heißt aber dann kann ich auch nicht vom
veranstalter klagen und sagen ich habe
14 tage antalya gebucht und den davon
zehn tage im hotel eingesperrt worden
ich möchte mein geld zurück
das doch das ist was anderes also wenn
immer mit einer pauschalreise unterwegs
ist und es passiert tatsächlich so wie
sie es jetzt in einem beispiel erwähnt
haben dass während des fluges die
einreisebestimmungen so verschärft
werden dass sich sofort in quarantäne
muss und vorher war das eben nicht so
dann kann ich auch während der reise
also ich habe die reise schon angetreten
den rücktritt erklären beziehungsweise
die kündigung und dann muss der
veranstalter mich auch zurück befördern
ob er das kann ob man diese quarantäne
dann umgehen können uns sofort wieder
zurückfliegen kann da steht auf einem
anderen blatt aber ich bin zumindest
meine ich rechtlos ich krieg zumindest
einen teil des reisepreises nachher
stadt schon eine spezial frage habe ich
jetzt auch noch was ist denn jetzt nicht
ausgangssperre wie haben wir ja zum
großen teil in deutschland oder in große
vielen vielen bundesländern und ich habe
im flieger wo ich quasi dazu gezwungen
bin während der ausgangssperre entweder
vom flughafen nach hause zu fahren oder
zum flughafen zu fahren oder ich möchte
nach zug nehmen nach münchen zu meiner
freundin um mal was anderes zu sehen
geht es zurzeit also bei denen nach zug
habe ich so meine probleme denn es gibt
ja viele zu ihren tag fahren und da
sagen eben die behörden man muss seine
reisen so planen dass man eben nicht in
die ausgangssperre kommt bei
festgelegten flügen sehe ich es als
jurist anders aber das streiten juristen
sehr drüber also ich sehe es als als
ausnahmetatbestand dass man hier von der
ausgangssperre nicht umfasst ist wenn
man einen flug bereits gebucht hat und
den eben frühmorgendliche antreten will
und deswegen meine wegen um 2 uhr das
haus schon verlassen möchte oder
umgekehrt ich komm zurück und lan erst
um 22 uhr irgendwo in frankfurt und muss
dann noch nach hause fahren zum beispiel
zu mir bis nach würzburg da komme ich ja
erst nach der ausgangssperre an
das ist dann nicht bußgeld bewehrt also
sollte man da eine anzeige bekommen da
sollte man sich gegen wären also da bin
ich sehr auf seiten der reisenden dass
es hier
nicht von der ausgangssperre umfasst ist
so jetzt wollte ich gerade schon sagt
das war's anfragen aber hier ist noch
einer von ihnen die als birkholz können
wir kurz noch mal zeigen wir auf dem
rechner
was ist wenn die touristische
übernachtungen wieder verboten wird
während ich im urlaub bin hatten wir
auch letztes jahr teilweise schon also
ich erinnere mich ich musste dann von
für sofort abreisen bin quasi
rausgeschmissen worden
ja da kommt dann darauf an was dann
passiert vor ort wird es so wie bei
ihnen seien dann wird sofort
rausgeschmissen dann bekommt man
natürlich für die tage die man nicht in
anspruch genommen hat den hotelpreis
erstattet dann ist übrigens ganz egal ob
ich als idee individual- tourist
unterwegs bin oder als pauschaltourist
im rahmen einer pauschalreise so hier
die nicht erbrachten leistungen müssten
dann erstattet werden aber wenn die
anordnung kommt touristen müssten jetzt
wieder weg dann muss man eben auch
leider folge leisten und die airline die
wie ich gebucht habe jetzt zum beispiel
als individualtouristen kann die dann
sagen ja dann kostet nochmal 200 euro
mehr oder muss die einfach dann umbuchen
da kommt es dann darauf an wenn ich als
pauschalreisender unterwegs bin dann
gehört ja der rückflug also wenn es
jetzt keine deutschlandreise ist sondern
der rückflug aus dem ausland mit zum
reisevertrag und da muss dann der
reiseveranstalter mir ein ersatzangebot
anbieten und zwar ohne mehrkosten sie
sehen wieder ein pluspunkt für die
pauschalreise
aber ich will die pauschalreisen jetzt
nicht verkaufen ich sage nur die
rechtlichen verbesserungen die man
dadurch hat und der individual- tourist
ist in der tat so dass der einen
ersatzflug selbst buch muss und der
kriegt nur für den nicht in anspruch
genommenen flug mit teil erstattung aber
den neuen flug die mehrkosten trägt
alleine also der ist ganz klar
schlechter tag also urlaub 2021 bleibt
kompliziert und ist ein fall teilweise
für den rechtsanwalt vielen dank dass
ihr heute abend für uns zeit hatten die
fragen beantwortet haben vielen dank
auch für eure fragen und für eure
kommentare und ich wünsche uns jetzt
allen ein schönes erstes mai wochenende
bleibt vielleicht da wo es nicht so voll
ist und versucht große
menschenansammlungen weiterhin zu
vermeiden scheint mir in der derzeitigen
lage immer noch
die beste idee zu sein wir sehen uns
wieder nächste woche hier an dieser
stelle ich freue mich drauf und sagt bis
bald macht's gut
und tschüss